Quick, you have two seconds to name these two countries
You're wrong!
Unless you got it right
Then good job!
They are of course Honduras and El Salvador
One thing these two countries have in common is being fanatic about Football
Or if you're a freedom-loving patriot , Soccer
But do they love it so much, they would go to war over it?
You bet they would
And that is NO BUENO
If you look at these two countries you might notice one major difference, and that is that this one is a lot bigger than this one
However, this one had a larger population than this one, made up mostly of farmers
And there wasn't enough land for them to live and work on, so they started moving from El Salvador to Honduras in search of land
And by the 1960s a huge number of illegal immigrants had crossed over the border from El Salvador
Meanwhile in Honduras, it's 1963 and this guy has just staged a military coup to prevent the rise of Communism
And is now the military leader of the country
He immediately began harassing the peasants' unions and other left-wing groups
But he's a little insecure about the legitimacy of his leadership, so he holds an election and wins
But then the opposing party says, "Hey man, that election was clearly corrupt and fraudulent
And also you've been bribed by the rich American banana companies who are taking all of our bananas tax-free
And now our economy is in ruins"
And everyone started to get mad at him
Now if you ever find yourself the barely
legitimate military leader of a corrupt Central American country and you start getting into hot water
Here's a bit of advice that has been tried and tested throughout the centuries
Blame something else
So he blamed the Salvadoran immigrants for stealing all the land and all the jobs and ruining Honduras
The immigrants found themselves under attack by the hostile locals
Egged on by the rich American banana companies who wanted all the bananas to themselves
The Honduran government began evicting Salvadoran immigrants
Who had been living on the land for generations
And started sending them back to El Salvador
The Salvadoran elite were furious and protested, citing moral reasons
But in reality, they were just getting a little too crowded
So tensions were about as high as they could be, but then
FOOOOTBAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAALL
It's the 1970 World Cup qualifiers and both countries finished top of their qualifying tables
So it's now time for them to play against each other in a series of matches
The first match took place in Honduras
The night before the game, Hondurans gathered outside the Salvadoran team's hotel making noise and taunting them
The next day, Honduras defeated the exhausted Salvadorans with a late 90th minute goal
After the match, a young Salvadoran fan, unable to bear her country's defeat, shot herself
Disturbingly, the Salvadoran government glorified the incident and made her into a national hero
And at the next game, fans brought pictures of her to the stadium
Emotions were running high as the next match took place in El Salvador and this time the tables were turned
The Hondurans had to endure a sleepless night in their hotel
And the next day, before the match started, instead of the Honduran flag, the Salvadorans raised a dirty rag
So great job at reducing tensions
El Salvador won decisively over the exhausted Hondurans
While spectators battled in the stands, team Honduras fled home in a bulletproof bus with rocks being thrown at them
And the Honduran coach reportedly told his players that they were lucky they lost
In response to the defeat
Hondurans began terrorising the Salvadoran settlers even more
In some cases reportedly throwing them off their land and burning down their homes
And the immigrants began fleeing back to El Salvador
The final game in Mexico would decide who went to the World Cup
It was close
But El Salvador came out victorious, knocking Honduras out of the tournament
The atmosphere was riotous, literally
And back in Honduras attacks on the Salvadoran immigrants further increased
This was too much for El Salvador to bear, with its people under attack
And an unmanageable refugee crisis on its hands
El Salvador severed all diplomatic ties with Honduras and declared WAR
The Football War is also known as the 100 Hours War because that's how long it lasted
Making it one of the shortest wars in history
El Salvador started by carrying out air raids in strat egic locations within Honduras
Including Toncontin International Airport
Which prevented the Honduran Air Force from getting into the sky
Then, with their superior army, they began an invasion along two major roads complete with light tanks and infantry
Their advance was rapid and they were quickly approaching the Honduran capital
Then the Organization of American States met in a bit of a panic
And unanimously agreed that war between El Salvador and Honduras
Was a bad thing and probably shouldn't continue
So they went to El Salvador and said, "can you please stop invading?"
And El Salvador declared, "NOT UNTIL THEY STOP BEING JERKS!!!!"
And so the war went on
The Honduran Air Force finally got into the sky
And with aid from neighboring Nicaragua
They successfully carried out air raids in Salvadoran air bases and oil facilities
Crippling the Salvadoran supply line and stopping their advance dead
Caught in a bit of a stalemate, the situation was no longer advantageous to El Salvador
So when the Organization of American States once again asked them to stop and agreed to ensure the safety of the Salvadoran immigrants
El Salvador relented and a ceasefire was organized on the 18th of July
Then the OAS said, "can you now please withdraw your troops from Honduras?"
"No"
- "Please"
- "No"
"Do it or we'll sanction you"
"You know what?"
"Just for you"
"I'll do it"
So El Salvador pulled its troops out of Honduras on the 2nd of August and with casualties in the thousands,
The war was over
The economies of both nations were damaged by the war
And El Salvador didn't have the capability to take care of all the returning immigrants
A crisis that eventually helped cause a civil war
The war left behind land and border disputes
Some of which are still a cause of tension to this day
El Salvador went on to play in the World Cup, but lost every match they played
And didn't make it past the group stage
So in the end nobody achieved anything and there were no winners
Except for this guy